Everything you believe about talent is
wrong. It doesn't exist. Those guitar
gods you worship, the artists you
admire, they're not gifted.
They just practiced when you were
sleeping. Child prodigies average 10,000
hours of practice by age 12. That's not
talent. That's showing up every single
day. But here's the secret everyone
misses. Excellence has a blueprint.
three simple pillars. First, break
skills into tiny pieces. You don't learn
guitar. You master finger positioning,
then strumming, then transitions.
Second, immediate feedback. Without it,
you're just reinforcing mistakes.
Third, the Goldilock zone. Challenges
exactly 4% harder than your current
skill. Too easy? Boredom. Too hard, you
quit. Here's what blows my mind.
improved just 1% daily and in one year
you're not 365% better you're 37 times
better. The British cycling team proved
this. They optimized everything by 1%.
Bike seats, pillows, even painted trucks
white to spot dust. 5 years later,
Olympic domination.
Your environment is stronger than your
willpower.
So design it. Guitar on the couch, not
the closet. Books everywhere, social
media deleted. 6 months from now, you'll
be exceptional at something. The only
question is what? Every expert was once
a disaster. They just had a system. Now
you do, too.